two videos ago we learned about
half-lives and we saw that they're good
if we are trying to figure out how much
of a compound we have left after one
half-life or two half-life or three
half-lives we can just take half of the
compound at every period but it's not as
useful if we're trying to figure out how
much of a compound we have after one
half of a half-life or after one day or
ten seconds or ten billion years and to
solve to address that issue in the last
video I proved and it involved a little
bit of sophisticated math and if you
haven't taken calculus you can really
just skip that video you don't have to
watch it for an intro math class but if
you're curious that's where we prove the
following formula at any given point of
time if you have some decaying some
decaying atom some element it can be
described as the amount of element you
have at any period of time is equal to
the amount you start it off with times e
to some constant in the last video I use
lambda I could use K this time minus K
times T and then for a particular
element with a particular half-life you
can just solve for the K and then apply
it to your problem so let's do that in
this video just so that all of these
variables can become a little bit more
concrete so let's figure out the general
formula for carbon carbon-14 that's the
one that we addressed in the half-life
we saw that carbon-14 has a half-life of
5730 years so let's see what that if we
can somehow take this information and
apply it to this equation so this tells
us that after one half-life so T is
equal to 5730 n of 5,730 is equal to the
amount we start off with so we're
starting off with well we're starting
off with n sub 0 times e to the minus
wherever you see the T you put the minus
5,700 you put the 5730 so minus K times
5730 that's how many years have gone by
and half-life tells us that after five
thousand seven hundred and thirty years
we'll have half of our initial sample
left so we'll have half of our initial
sample yet left so if we try to solve
this equation
4k what do we get divide both sides by
and not get rid of a t variable and then
we're left with E to the minus 5730 K
I'm just switching these two around is
equal to 1/2 if we take the natural log
of both sides what do we get we get
natural log of e to anything the natural
log of e to the a is just a so the
natural log of this is minus 5730 K is
equal to the natural log of 1/2 I just
took the natural log of both sides
natural log and natural log of both
sides of that and so to solve for K we
could just say K is equal to K is equal
to the natural log of 1/2
/ - 5730 which we did in the previous
video but let's see if we can let's do
that again here to avoid for those of
you who might have skipped it so if you
have 1/2 0.5 take the natural log and
then you divide it by 5732 negative 5730
you get 1.2 times 10 to the negative 4
so it equals 1.2 times 10 to the minus 4
so now we have the general formula for
carbon-14 given its half-life at any
given point in time after our starting
point so this is for let's call this for
carbon-14 for C 14 the amount of
carbon-14 we're going to have left is
going to be the amount that we started
with times e to the minus K K we just
solved for 1.2 times 10 to the minus 4
times the amount of time that has passed
by this is our formula for carbon if we
were do it for carbon-14 if we were
doing this for some other element we
would use that elements half-life to
figure out how much we're going to have
at any given period of time to figure
out the K value so let's use this to
solve a problem let's say that I start
off with I don't know let's say I start
off with
300 grams of carbon carbon 14 carbon 14
and I want to know how much do I have
after after I don't know after 2000
years 2000 years how much do I have well
I just plug into the formula n of 2000
is equal to the amount that I started
off with 300 grams times e to the minus
1.2 times 10 to the minus 4 times T is
times 2000 times
mm so what is that that's so I already
have that 1.2 times 10 to the minus 4
there so let me say times 2000 equals
and of course this there's a negative
out there so let me put the negative
number out there so this is a negative
and I have to raise e to this power so
it's 0.2 for 1 so this is equal to so n
of 2000 the amount of the substance I
can expect after 2000 years is equal to
300 times e to the minus 0.2 for 1/9 and
let's see does my does my my calculator
doesn't have an e to the power so let me
just take e I need to get a better
calculator I should get my scientific
calculator back but E is let's say 2.7
one I could keep adding digits but I'll
just do 2.7 1 to the point 2 4 negative
which is equal to 0.78 times the amount
that I started off with times 300 times
300 which is equal to 236 grams so this
is equal to 236 grams so just like that
using this exponential decay formula I
was able to figure out how much of the
carbon I have after kind of an unusual
period of time a non half-life period of
time let's do another one like this
let's say let's go the other way around
let's say I'm trying to figure out let's
say I start off with
let's say I start off with 400 grams of
c14 and I want to know how long so I
want to I don't I want to know I want to
a certain amount of time does it take
for me to get to 350 grams of c14 so you
just say that 350 grams is how much I'm
ending up with it's equal to the amount
that I started off with 400 grams times
e to the minus K that's minus 1.2 times
10 to the minus 4 times time and now we
solve for time how do we do that well we
could divide both sides by 400 what's
300 350 divided by 400 350 by 400 7/8
so 0.875 so you get 0.875 is equal to e
to the minus 1.2 times 10 to the minus
4t you take the natural log of both
sides get the natural log of 0.875 is
equal to the natural log of e to
anything is just the anything so it's
equal to minus 1.2 times 10 to the minus
4 T and so T is equal to this divided by
1.2 times 10 to the minus 4 so the
natural log point eight seven five
divided by minus 1.2 times 10 to the
minus four is equal to the amount of
time it would take us to get from 400
grams to 350 my cell phone is ringing
let me turn that off to 350 so let me do
the math so if you have 0.875 we want to
take the natural log of it natural log
and divide it by minus one point so
divided by one point to e for negative
10 to the negative 4 and this is all a
negative number oh I'll just divide it
by this and then just take the negative
of that equals that and have to take a
negative so this is equal to one
thousand one hundred and twelve years to
get from 400 to three
350 grams of my substance this might
seem a little complicated but you just
have to if there's one thing you just
have to do is you have to remember this
formula and if you want to know where it
came from watch the previous video for
any particular element you solve you
solve for this K value and then you just
substitute what you know and then solve
for what you don't know I'll do a couple
more of these in the next video